[Music]
welcome back to careful boys oh hello we
are lucky enough to have tesh with us
again yup
i like your sweater bro thanks man
because he's the voice of ken yeah fyi
i'm really promoting imdb trivia i now
use this as an opportunity i like how
you just gentrified the white guy
from within is that is that how that
worked from within from within or is it
outsourcing ooh was it outsourcing which
one is it
i am american
so he's getting paid for dollars he's
he's white facing dude yeah you're
taking white jobs bro
you're taking white jobs man
they're worried they're you know people
where you're like building the walls and
we're already here man
we're inside we're inside the wall i'm
inside the wall and i'm inside your head
they're worried about the wrong brown
people dude they didn't think about the
east like the indian people the real the
real browns that are taking their jobs
is this one you know hours
the real browns
i mean they were looking for us first
you know columbus was looking for me
columbus was looking for my great great
grandparents he was like ah you got a
good tan you're in here you're the first
objective yeah dude congrats congrats on
your uh definition please thank you by
the way thank you bro yeah man it's
awesome still a hundred percent i'm
still a hundred percent on rotten
tomatoes i wasn't maintaining that if
you haven't seen it go watch it go watch
it it's on netflix right now united
states canada new zealand australia in
the uk
all our asian countries i'm sorry
we're for sale anyone out there was
there a western release before asia
released uh we haven't negotiated a deal
with any uh asian territories yet so
hopefully that'll be next so if you guys
want to see it make sure you uh tag your
favorite streamers in in your home
countries and uh let's let's get some
buzz it's a great movie we do have a
hundred percent 100 really watching now
drop after this video it's very easy
watch all the haters come out
that's the most asian rating you can
have you know 100 percent you know it's
really funny so we i went on the imdb
page and like there's always haters
no matter what whatever and there was
one review that was like this movie
ain't diverse enough and i'm like if
you're trying to like hate on the movie
can't you can't you just at least like
find something legitimate that'd be like
oh the indian dude in the movie sucks
like something that remotely makes sense
there's not enough
movies it's an indian movie there's not
even that we have we have a bunch of
asians in the movie there's all kinds of
people yeah there's whites in there yeah
i mean
we cut that down yeah
no but there's all kinds there's all
kinds of people there's asians there's
all different types of asians i don't
wanna i don't wanna say who cause i want
people i want to leave with a mystery so
you go and you watch it
well you think they're trying to be
funny
oh yeah maybe they're being sarcastic
it's like going on um it's a terrible
joke no but it's not a funny joke
it would have been funny if the person
wrote i wish there was more white people
in this movie then i would have laughed
pretty funny yeah because what if what
if what if you're on django and you're
like it's not diverse enough that's
technically isn't this just white and
black
that's all american movies there's no
latinos no asians what is this person's
ideal diverse movie that's what i'm
saying how many like different
aliens in it i have a feeling that guy
that wrote that review wants more whites
in that movie oh
yeah
and he just feels like i'm not
represented in this movie it's not
reverse it's reversity it's reverse
diversity
[Laughter]
when there's movies that don't have
enough agents in it i go on the imdb i
make my account and i say there's not
this movie's not diverse what movie have
you said that too um jurassic park one
too many dinosaurs
jurassic park wait you reviewed jurassic
park one yeah with chris pratt yeah that
one
except for the one guy that had that is
there any um
i want to know if there's any prominent
asian paleontologists
except the guy in jurassic park who's
trying to ruin the world all day they
usually don't choose anthropology and
all these majors because they don't make
money they don't make money that's true
that's
like i was like dad i want to study
dinosaurs they're like
you want dinosaur i'll bury you in the
ground you know
what movie has the ideal amount of
diversity you guys think which one i do
i do
i do well but here's the thing
[Laughter]
but even that's kind of loaded though
because they like color-coded everything
if you were really trying to reflect the
planet every movie would only star
chinese and indians
you were trying to relax because we're
like two and a half billion of the seven
and a half billion people on this planet
if we got the world you know population
and every like however many population
your culture has that is the
representative then it has to be an
equal amount like so if chinese and
indians we would literally be a quarter
of the globe that would help my career a
lot it would help everyone at this table
would be making
just add another zero to everyone
ten dollars
can you imagine like
a world war ii biopic or something being
done by only chinese in india dude
that'd be awesome you know it's about
world war ii but come on
the world is chinese no it's it's really
it's really funny because a lot of times
when if i pitch material yeah
they'll be like ah you know i just
i just didn't get it i'm like what do
you mean you didn't get it of course you
didn't get it it's a story
about indian people for like indian
americans you're not an indian american
you're just like a white dude that's all
but you know who will get this the other
1 billion people that i wrote this movie
for
dude if 10 of india watches this movie
that's like a quarter of the u.s
population that's like super bowl
numbers
i got 100 million people to watch my
movie dude that's pretty sweet that's
pretty [ __ ] great
those are great numbers do you remember
that one production company we were
pitching to before
and then it was like the the bald white
dude with glasses and then he said our
idea wasn't good and then he was showing
us the samurai project oh yeah he wanted
you guys to be samurais no no no no it
was so [ __ ] hilarious this was a
white dude that pitched a samurai
project he uh he was one of those white
guys that like absolutely loved japanese
[ __ ] [ __ ] but then kind of got it
mixed up like he was like those old
school weebs you know like he was like
the guys that like i can't wait to go to
japan and get like a japanese wife but
then like yeah it was like those kind of
guys see literally the last samurai was
it
was it tom cruise i think he wanted i
think he wanted to be i think but his
body didn't fit athletically you know
what i mean like
he wasn't as beautiful as tommy
if if this was the metaverse that would
be his character you know nana versus
tom cruise we pitched in this show i
forgot which one it was was it the
schindler's list musical
and then and he was like no this that's
not going to work he goes you know
what's going to work he goes this show
i'm working on and it was like a cross
between he was like imagine if like sons
of anarchy but samurai
you're like i don't want to watch that
show and i was like isn't that ronan
warriors isn't that is that a show no
it was like a cartoon i used to watch it
can't remember it was like sci-fi with
samurai and then like the graphics look
like you know when you when you see a
comic book right it's like done in a
certain way and when they mix asian [ __ ]
it's all wrong it was like that kind of
concept art and i was looking at it like
yo this looks like weird and so he
wanted you guys to play the samurai no
he was just i think he was right he was
bragging about it he was just pitching
we were supposed to do the pitch to him
because he was the gatekeeper for the
[ __ ] you see how it works and then he
turned around and just wanted approval
from us and i was just like you guys
were his asian focus group
wow that's so weird and i was like all
right and we left the meeting going
what happened
did you guys write him a check
we'll buy it you were like how did this
happen we went in to go sell the show
and then we bought a show
we bought this futuristic samurai
we should do a reading of it on jk news
we should all play characters
[Laughter]
samurai sons of anarchy okay
yeah it was interesting samurai songs of
anarchy when you put it that way it's
like
it's kind of a cool idea i mean it
sounds funny yeah i know it's supposed
to be serious though i can't i can't
stop imagining like samurai motorcycles
see like my head went back to like you
know like charlotte
i think the the uh the like clan we it's
like the cl us versus everybody yeah and
then and they're going through town oh i
just thought it was a bunch of white
guys in america like in their
motorcycles wanting to be samurai
driving on their that would be better in
the modern era that's way better it's
going around all of these like japanese
they're just in samurai schools and
they're you know just destroying sushi
restaurants is that samurai the code
samurai is that bushido's the samurai
yeah yeah yeah yeah they're like we want
to learn the bushido con they're like
dude what the [ __ ] you guys are driving
motorcycles or it's a bunch of like real
hardcore bikers all white dudes but they
just love japanese culture and they want
to like so they're weebs biker weeds
biker weeds
yeah bro would they watch this show we
could pitch the show i think we're onto
something we might get counter pitched
i don't want to go in there man i'm
already we are
i want to see biker weebs i want them to
go up and down japan and then they can
do all the fanboy [ __ ] like they grew up
watching pokemon
you know and then you can just watch
these tatted up bikers girly men just
going like try to catch them all yeah
play pokemon go play [ __ ] monsters
they're on their bikes oh there's a
pokestop we gotta stop over here
look how quickly we took an idea and see
we're converting to something that would
be a hit yeah will anybody watch it i
don't know but it's fun tell us in the
comments
would you watch our show
about biker weebs going around japan
dominating gyms on pokemon go
they're just so misunderstood everyone
thinks they're up to no good but they're
just doing nerdy [ __ ] [ __ ] today's video
is brought to you by dipsy if you're
thinking about making a resolution this
year instead of depriving yourself why
not focus on providing for yourself with
dipsy you can focus on giving yourself
pleasure which is a habit that you'd
want to keep around all year dixie
stories is an app full of sexy audio
stories and now they even have brand new
written stories no matter who you're
into or what turns you on dipsy brings
the stories to life anytime anywhere
close your eyes and let yourself get
lost in a world where only good things
happen and pleasure is your only
priority
explore your fantasies in a safe
shame-free way yeah
there are hundreds of stories to choose
from and they release new content every
week so there's always more to explore
and they also have wellness sessions to
help you wind down and explore and sleep
sessions to help you drift off for
listeners of the show dipsy is offering
an extended 30-day free trial when you
go to dipsystories.com
off the record that's 30 days of full
access for free when you go to
d-i-p-s-e-a-s-t-o-r-i-e-s
dot com slash off the record that's
dipsy stories.com off the record you
know what we should have biker weebs
part two korea edition so then you have
kpop kit kit yeah
koreaboos versus biker weaves
and then they [ __ ] battle it out dude
they're like the mongols of the story
that's a real biker game yeah aren't
kpop fans already a gang they're pretty
gangsters they're army kids
they take people out do they really yeah
i mean i mean like you know when you get
they get mobbed they take people out
like
i remember during all these kind of
political stuff they were they were like
oh you [ __ ] with us bts army yeah bts
would do it well yeah because remember
when that dude like supported that
disqualified uh athlete and then
everyone started coming after him
there's like a creative athlete who i
guess was under um
investigation for having cheated but
then the one of the members was still
supporting them and so like all these
like i think a bunch of like chinese
people like flooded his instagram to be
like dude how dare you support him but
then like the army came through and they
just like
blocked i thought you meant the literal
army no
well yeah i was like wow literal korean
army talk about government funding the
response of the bts army is way more
efficient they came in and they just
like flooded his own comments so you
couldn't even see what all of china
would say to him
oh [ __ ] he put a bunch of organization
he's like we love you we love you we
love you we love you dude their
countermeasures are whoo
it's like you just call like asian
aunties in the in the bts army and
you've smashed together wow like
unstoppable horses
it's literally just like a black hole
yeah they'll just come in and just
annihilate everything that's what they
need to do like and like russia has
their troll farms right we need to hire
korean fans i was really thinking that
k-pop fans because it's actually
worldwide so we gotta enlist k-pop fans
to battle the cyber wars dude that's the
only way we balance modern warfare is
hella weird
[Laughter]
we should have bts army
get into fights with asian aunties
did you see it it'd be like a celebrity
death match yeah a fandoms
asian auntie so they're on facebook so
it's a different platform
you know like i don't know
in brown culture like asian aunties live
on whatsapp and circulating news yeah i
don't know if it's the same is what's up
like the biggest platform for like
indian yeah it's community i would just
assume so
i try to stay away do you guys get
random messages on whatsapp from chinese
ladies yes all the time i started
getting that hey uh this is amy do you
want to meet up for lunch
long time no see how are you yeah
this is joanna
well i had one he was you know an asian
girl like this is joanna um
i'm sorry i missed your call it was like
that and i'm like i don't respond
and then you look it said something
funny like oh this is fate this is like
the wrong phone number
oh man i'm like i wonder if you're like
a 50 year old white dude in a basement
right now i really want to ryan battles
those guys all the time i love you how
are you taking people you take out
scammers oh i try to i try to waste as
much of their time as possible
they don't respond to me
i want to flirt i think they know people
are starting to do that [ __ ] so they
just like give up yeah oh remember that
guy that texted me and i put it in the
group right
you put him in a group should we call
him let's go i put him in boys to men
the revival group
okay this is what he said he goes uh
hello my friend what are your plans for
christmas
and i said my brother i lost all my
contacts my deepest apologies is this
muhammad akbar
and then and he didn't reply so i said
and i wrote muhammad i told you many
times don't play [ __ ] games with me
i go i wait five minutes and you know
talk back when i see you next time and i
went dot dot and he goes aren't you sam
wait i thought you were muhammad now
you're sam
and then he goes he says aren't you sam
and i go are you [ __ ] with me you know
damn well
this is brahim
i like your deep cut
this names [ __ ] i got i really got the
wrong number yeah he's like [ __ ] dude
he's like my bad [ __ ] is going up
those are the kind of things you should
read for for roles
on like the top 100 middle eastern names
he's like i'll go with number one
muhammad now let me go to like name 52.
accurate those are some elaborate scams
they're doing now though like they they
they do this whole like setup to like
flirt with you and then they as soon as
they get your dick pic it's
oh
that's what they're that's what they're
working up to they're trying it's a dick
pic that's right
i guarantee you guys send uh someone
else's dick send a dick
they will go boom we're gonna send this
to your family we're gonna put this out
blah blah unless you pay us this much so
how would they know what your family's
if that's happened to my friends they
just go to your socials and then they go
oh here's all your facebook yeah
everybody wow
so you can know by your phone number i
guess so
so if they message you say hey what's up
how are you friend and if you send him a
dick pic right away is that the right
way to do it or should i flirt back a
little bit
what's the social etiquette
how do i do this right hello how are you
on your dick
so that it's two and one and you save on
the uh text got it got it got it got i
got it and you sent your mom's contact
already so it's easier oh yeah here's my
family's information
please text this picture to my mom and
my please blackmail me because they see
me so i know what they're saying do
everything expeditiously yeah and just
get it out there already so just you
know cut the middle ground right it's a
crazy thing man people be falling for
that and the same thing happens on offer
up man
you send a dick pic on offer
can you sell it though are you offering
are you selling your ticket
but like you're like best off for five
dollars like some people just put like
that they know everyone's gonna want
it's like really cheap whatever it is
and then you go hey do you still have it
and they'll go yeah um do you want to
come by later tonight oh by the way my
husband won't be home it's it'll just be
this thing stuff what
yeah it's really like wow yeah it's
weird why could you try to buy like a
stool or something i don't know what
like any like if you go in there and you
find any item that's too good to be true
chances are it's going to be one of
those scams you look up do you guys look
up the people that you buy stuff from
yeah
as well yeah like you're on social media
so what happens if someone oh marshall's
like oh and they'd be like oh man this
guy's well my [ __ ] dancer i should say
like
[Laughter]
my profile pic is like a photoshop
version of one of my friends and then my
name on there is jermaine dufrey
you're like [ __ ] he's super famous
but it's funny
get it get it we only got five seconds
sometimes i forget i forget what i put
it under and then when i go to meet him
up and i'm just waiting and some guys
like jeremy
yeah switch it with the g sometimes yeah
but it's really funny when people are
like oh hey thanks jermaine like i love
the cabinet
how [ __ ] is that
that's funny that's great i don't think
anyone should put their real [ __ ]
because like i i have a lot of like
friends that are girls and they get hit
on consoles yeah yeah yeah yeah on offer
up or especially if they come [ __ ] if
they pick it up at your house and they
know where you live now it's so
dangerous don't do that like set a
meet-up place like it's not your house
i'm too lazy like what i got my truck i
needed to sell my wheels i'm like just
come and pick up the no
you're [ __ ] famous too like what the
[ __ ]
you're famous bro you [ __ ] idiot
[ __ ] famous this guy dude what the
[ __ ] i'm mohammed dude
i'll kill you
i don't honestly i don't think people
are gonna be messing with bart cause he
probably you come out like in your
underwear and you're like here's my
truck here are my wheels and he's like
pressing both of the wheels and you're
like how am i supposed to carry he's
like carry like a man
catch it yeah
he's like what do you use this for oh i
use it just a [ __ ] deadlift what are
you gonna use it for i'm gonna put it on
my truck
oh that's a that's a [ __ ] [ __ ] thing
to do
do how do you have people meet you up at
your house when you have like this guy
has zip ties in this car you know that i
do he has for restraining purposes and i
think that's probably up there
of these risks cable management for a
cable management truck but it's
literally in a handcuff form it's pretty
crazy it's for big cables
what are you [ __ ] tapping off the
power grip tesla chargers
it's for his quadriceps when he's
testing the circumference oh he's like
after he gets his pump on he's like then
he tries to break him
[Laughter]
so that really sucks with the digging
jim's like why are there all these
broken zip ties everywhere it's the
fastest way to get swole remember you
guys never done that you need to have
that sign in your gym clean up your zip
ties
rack your weights
[Laughter]
don't leave them on the floor [ __ ] i
didn't think of that
people are using like the bands to just
flex they're not using it to stretch or
anything oh yeah all the meat heads but
yeah that's it maybe you should get
somebody else to play you during
off-road transactions but do you buy
stuff from off-rope and craigslist too
because i do 90 some percent of people
they just tell me to go to their house
you just roll up and then they're just
like yeah whatever that's also dumb
i bought some stuff nationwide too and
they just mailed it to me to your house
yeah yeah
dude when i bought i bought an arcade
machine like that one like a very small
one and then when i uh got to the guy's
house like super late at night he goes
yeah just park in the driveway and then
uh he like opens his gate and then i
pulled into his driveway and then he he
shut the gate behind my car and i'm like
oh no let's say again why would you do
that like my husband's not home
oh that's a pity
you won't steal [ __ ] and drive off i
guess so yeah i mean he ended up being
totally legit and i went in there and he
was like a great dude and then yeah but
then you let you out yeah
he was and then my car's still there and
then
you spent 48 hours in his basement i
don't remember i don't remember anything
i suppressed everything you're like you
felt went great and then i woke up and
stuck home
four days later yeah i don't know what
happened yeah like there's a lot of like
really sketch ways that that could start
out man it's scary thanks jeremy
[Music]
you